Bladesmiths,
welcome to The Forge.
In past competitions,
we've had smiths come
and we've asked them
to layer steel
so that they could create
Damascus patterns
like Raindrop, Ladder,
and Sharktooth
And today, we're gonna ask
a similar task of you guys,
except we don't want just
one of these patterns,
we want them all.
What we have here
are the bits and pieces
of pattern Damascus billets
that are Raindrop, Sharktooth,
and Ladder pattern.
And you'll have to
take these bits,
load them into the cans,
combine that
with powdered steel
to create a
Fossil Damascus billet
from which you will forge
your signature blades
in your signature style.
Good luck, gentlemen.
Your three hours starts... now.
How difficult is this challenge?
Honestly, you've got really good
steels you're working with.
The biggest challenge
is packing
everything into that can.
With all these different-sized
pieces and shapes,
they've got to make sure
that they're filling in
all the gaps
with that 1095 powder
or they're just not gonna
get a good weld.
The only way I have any clue
on how to do Canister Damascus
is from watching a video
that J. Nielson put out,
so I'm gonna try my best
to do what he did.
J. used Wite-Out,
I'm gonna use Wite-Out.
J. inset his top cap
on the canister,
I'm gonna inset my top cap
on the canister.
Smart work. It actually
makes the canister
a lot more structurally strong.
[Jesse] I decide to go
with the small cubes.
My thought is
it's less material per one
and it'll heat up faster.
And from my experience,
the smaller piece
is actually easier to compact
and make it one
solid billet.
[Wil] Why would you peel
two cans
when you can peel one?
Doesn't make any sense to me.
I have one canister in the forge
right now heating up
while I'm getting
the other one prepped.
That way we'll get
a cycle going
so both of 'em
will be good.
Take 'em apart,
forge weld 'em together,
should have a knife.
I am notorious
for working messy.
God, it's a mess.
Wilson's, like, smearing
Wite-Out all over everything.
[J.] Like a van Gogh painting
over there.
What are you doing
to our table over there, man?!
-I'll clean it up!
-All right.
[Jesse] So I take
my super hot canister
over to the squaring dies
on the hydraulic press.
And I want to squish it down
a little at a time,
and I'm gonna keep going
until this is solid.
That's how you do it.
That's how you set your welds.
Get that square can,
you're pushing all four sides
at the same time,
compressing everything evenly.
[Wil] Teddy has two small
canisters he's dealing with.
[Teddy] So I grab the first can,
just smash, smash, smash.
The second one, same thing.
I'm excited.
I can tell by the way it's
smashing it's being spill set,
it's gonna be good.
I can't wait any longer.
Here goes nothin'!
Whoo! That's hot!
I give it a good press
all the way down,
I turn it 90 degrees,
do another press
all the way down,
I do a pass on the Big BLU.
That rod is hot
as a two-dollar pistol!
Normally at home,
I'd do at least two passes
on the squaring dies,
but I go with my gut
that it's a good weld.
-Oh, that can is hot!
-[whirring]
[David] I don't believe
that those welds
are consolidated
in that billet he's got
after one run on the press.
[muttering indistinctly]
Wilson's still got problems
up in that blade
from that initial weld.
[Doug] So if Wilson's billet
does have some cracks in it,
is it best to chop them up
and try to forge weld 'em
all over again?
[J.] I'd try to grind them out.
Just get rid of 'em.
Make 'em disappear,
then you can stretch it out.
[Wilson] I know that
I can't grind it out.
To me, my only option is
to try to weld it.
[Wil] We got Wilson over
here welding,
and welding is... a bad thing
at this point.
It's not a good sign.
Man, Jesse's got
a cool-lookin' blade.
Yeah, I like it.
And we got a quenched blade.
Teddy quenched.
We have three quenched blades
out there on The Forge floor.
Bladesmiths!
Shut down your machines!
Drop your tools! This first
round of competition is over!
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test.
We got the bone chop here.
I'ma take each of your blades
and I'm gonna baton them
through these very large,
very dense bones.
What your blades do to the bones
I'm not too concerned about.
I wanna see what the bones
do to your blades.
Teddy, you ready
to rock and roll?
-Let's do this.
-Let's do it.
[intense music playing]
[grunts]
[tense music playing]
[J.] Good job, Teddy.
Your edge is fine.
There's a couple tiny little
glints I can see on the edge.
-But overall, good job.
-Thank you.
-How you feeling, Jesse?
-I'm ready.
-Good, so am I.
-Go nuts.
-I'm halfway there already.
-[laughter]
[intense music playing]
[grunts]
Oh, my gosh.
[chuckles]
-Nice job, Jesse.
-Thank you.
You did lose a little bit
of your fine edge,
but overall,
knife's fairly comfortable.
-You survived. Good job.
-Thank you.
How you feeling, Wilson?
I'm ready for you to do
whatever J. does.
This is what I do.
Then do it to it.
-[grunts]
-[intense music playing]
[grunts]
-Yes!
-Unbelievable.
[laughs]
Good job, Wilson.
-You made it through.
-Made it through. [chuckles]
[J.] The only thing I see,
there's not much edge
pretty much from here up.
Okay.
But striking the bone...
didn't roll anything,
didn't chip it out.
-Good job.
-Thank you.
Dave.
Gentlemen, you've survived
our strength test.
Now onto the sharpness test.
The apple slice.
Unlike the strength test,
this is all about
what your blades do
to those apples.
Looking for a good, clean cut.
Teddy, you're up first. Ready?
-Let's do it.
-[David] All right.
[dramatic music playing]
[chuckles] Man.
[softly] Fudge.
So, Teddy, your knife is
definitely sharp.
But if you look at the tip,
it's kinda got a warp this way.
It's flat on one side,
it's ground on the other.
When I hit those apples,
you can actually see it
in the apples,
it just goes "swish,"
and rides up right up
out of 'em.
It affects the cut,
but it doesn't affect the fact
that this is still
a sharp blade.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
All right, Jesse,
you're up next.
-You ready for this?
-Yes, sir.
[David] Okay.
[sharp exhale]
[intense music playing]
Man.
All right, Jesse.
There's some damage
to this edge.
It's a really obtuse edge.
You can see that the slice
kinda goes halfway through
that apple
and it cracks it off after that
'cause the blade gets so wide.
Not the sharpest thing
on the planet, but it'll do it.
-Good job.
-Thank you.
All right, Wilson. You're up.
-Cut it.
-[chuckles] Okay.
[intense music playing]
[snickers]
So, yeah, it is sharp.
But it's just wedging
them apart.
And yeah, I could probably chop
wood with this,
but for slicing apples,
it's just got the wrong
edge geometry.
I understand.
[Wil] Bladesmiths, the judges'
deliberation is complete.
They've made their
final decision.
It's time for one of you smiths
to leave The Forge.
The Bladesmith leaving
The Forge is...
[tense music playing]
Wilson, your blade
didn't make the cut
and David Baker's gonna
tell you why.
Wilson, your blade's heavy,
it has an obtuse edge,
and it was really designed
only for one of our tests.
But before we let you go,
I wanna tell you
that rarely
have we seen a smith
work so hard to get around
what looked like
insurmountable problems.
You pushed to the very end,
made it through that
strength test,
and I'm just really proud
of what you did.
Thank you.
Wilson, please surrender
your blade.
[Wilson] This has been
an excellent experience.
It's showed me that I have
the drive to keep going
and going
even when things
are not turning out right
and are not gonna
turn out right.
But you have to do
the best you can
and keep going at it.